for me and for my wife you know of
course there's a lot of stuff that hurts
especially when the majority is untrue
I'll not be bullying into into into
playing a game that's they killed my
mother
Harry dropping a bombshell about British
tabloids just one of the many
revelations he and wife Megan Marco make
to journalist Tom Bradby in the new
documentary Harry and Megan in African
journey and we're breaking down all the
biggest moments starting with Prince
Harry adorably revealing that even
Archie loves Africa at number six
megan marco proudly identifying as a
woman of color when i made the choice to
add those words into the speech it's
really the last minute and I said to
Harry like what do you think I add this
in I don't know it just felt right
before I was part of this family that's
how I identified with people in
connection you know as a mother now as a
wife now but just as a woman and as a
woman of color which has been brought to
the forefront in a more prominent way
harry opening up about the lingering
trauma from losing his mother princess
diana is our number five moment do you
feel at peace in a way yet or is it
still out sort of wound that Fester's I
think probably wound that Fester's every
single time I see a camera every single
time I hear a click every single time I
see a flash it takes me straight back
what happens is incredibly brought every
single day and that's not me being
paranoid that's just me not wanting a
repeat of the past and if anybody else
knew what I knew
if better father better husband than
anyone you do should probably do be
doing exactly what I'm doing as well at
number four Harry addressing rumors of a
rift between him and his older brother
Prince William we don't see each other
as much as we as much as we used to
because we're so busy but you know I
love him dearly and you know the
majority of the stuff is probably well
the majority of stuff is created I have
nothing but you know it's just as
brothers you know good days you have bad
days and rounding out at number three is
harry revealing whether a move to africa
is on the table I don't know where I
don't know where we could live in Africa
with all the problems that are going on
now I just don't see how we'd be able to
to really make as much difference as we
want to you know the issues and the
judgment of how how we would be with all
those surroundings at number two Megan
being warned that tabloids would destroy
her life when I first met my now husband
my friends were really happy because I
was so happy but my British friend said
to me
I'm sure he's great but because the
British tabloids will destroy your life
we rarely get the opportunity to see
Megan be candid about her personal life
so her response to whether she can
handle the pressure topped the
noteworthy moments I really tried to
adopt this British sensibility of a
stiff upper lip but I think that what
that does internally is probably really
damaging and the biggest thing that I
know is that I ever thought that this
would be easy but I thought it would be
fair
and that's the part that's really hard
to reconcile but um I don't know the
good thing is I've got my baby and I've
got my husband oh yeah and we also
learned her pet name for Prince Harry
I've said for a long time to H the
documentary which debuted on ITV in the
UK on Sunday airs in the u.s. Wednesday
night on ABC